au Canada l'agriculture génère 10% des
gaz à effet de serre comparé à d'autres
grands secteurs comme la production
d'énergie ou encore les transports c'est
relativement peu mais qu'est-ce qui émet
des GES en agriculture et comment
mesurer l'empreinte carbone d'une ferme
prise individuellement on est allé à la
rencontre d'agriculteurs et de
chercheurs qui se sont posés exactement
ces questions là
c'est le début de l'été chez Eric
Lapierre à Saint-Nazaire d'acte dans
Montérégie sa terre compte 400 hectares
de grandes cultures mes objectifs
le plus bas afin d'assurer une pérennité
financière mais en gardant un empreinte
environnementale plus basse possible
c'est là avec ce réflexion là que j'ai
commencé un peu à challenger mon
agronome
Eric m'avait déjà demandé Mélanie
j'aimerais ça calculer mes si mon
empreinte carbone à la ferme puis là je
mets du bon comme ok comment moi en tant
que conseiller comment je peux faire ça
quel outil je peux avoir pour faire ce
bilan là puis pour moi c'est comme il y
a j'avais besoin de faire des recherches
puis on va regarder avec les unsac mais
le bord pourrait peut-être être une
un élément à regarder il y a 20 ans à
l'époque où Mélanie Hardy étudier en
agronomie on ne parlait pas de gaz à
effet de serre de GES à la ferme et même
aujourd'hui difficile de trouver des
repères on parle toujours
l'environnement par jour bon je disais
ok chaque petit geste compte mais le
problème c'est qu'on ne sait pas on n'a
pas d'idées on n'est pas capable de
chiffrer c'est dur de demander à
quelqu'un on dit bon faut réduire
mais si on sait pas notre point A
comment qu'on veut réduire se rendre un
point B
l'agriculteur et son agronome croise
alors sur leur chemin agric climat un
projet financé par le ministère de
l'Environnement du Québec depuis 2017 le
but d'agrikima en fait au tout début
c'était vraiment de s'approprier ce que
ça veut dire les changements climatiques
en agriculture c'était de comprendre
quel effet cela chez les producteurs
comment ça va les affecter positivement
ou négativement puis comment s'adapter à
tout ça
rapidement les agronomes et autres
chercheurs d'agricula sont confrontés
aux questions des agriculteurs question
pour lesquelles ils ont bien peu de
réponses
est-ce que j'en ai mis un saut des jeux
et moi je participe aussi à ça puis si
oui ben ça ressemble à quoi mon bilan
est-ce que je peux faire des changements
ou de faire des choix d'entreprise qui
tiendraient compte de tout ça l'idée de
faire le bilan GES des 38 fermes
participantes s'imposent alors s'il
existe des calculateurs qui permettent
aux simples citoyens de mesurer son
empreinte carbone en quelques clics de
souris à l'échelle d'une ferme c'est un
petit peu plus compliqué parce que selon
le climat le type de sol la superficie
de la ferme les cultures des animaux
qu'on élève ou pas les résultats peuvent
être complètement différents et jusqu'à
tout récemment au Québec il n'existait
pas d'outils convivial pour mesurer
l'empreinte GES d'une ferme
[Musique]
exercice de grande revue littérature au
président ça comme ça avec tout ce qui
se faisait comme recherche comme études
québécoise qui était suffisamment validé
par les Pères pour qu'on l'utilise dans
calculateur ce calculateur a permis de
produire pour la première fois un
portrait GES de ferme dans le contexte
québécois les fermes pilotes sont comme
des collaborateurs avec nous pour
utiliser un nouvel outil puis s'assurer
qu'il soit utilisable par un grand
nombre de producteurs la consommation
d'énergie c'est seulement 8% de tes
émotions
ton principal en fait pose des missions
c'est vraiment les prototype d'azote du
sol ce jour-là Charlotte Caudron
agriculum présente le bilan carbone de
la ferme d'Eric et comme ailleurs ce
diagnostic donne lieu à certaines
surprises
Eric satanait à entendre parler du
carburant qu'il utilise dans sa
machinerie
protéines que moi je pensais être mon
principal poste et en réalité
8% de mon émission exactement de GS le
92 autres pour cent et ailleurs
exactement en tout début on leur posait
la question on sait c'est quoi que vous
pensez que votre poste d'édition le plus
important et puis la grande majorité pas
tous mais la grande majorité peu importe
le type de production répondait
probablement mon tracteur en écarte ça
m'a fait beaucoup de passages en
chantier puis on entend parler du
transport mais chez Eric comme dans
toutes les fermes de grandes cultures ce
qui polluent le plus c'est le sol le
principal c'est vraiment le protoxyde
d'azote des sols donc faites les
émissions des sols le protoxyde d'azote
est un gaz à effet de serre méconnu et
pourtant son potentiel réchauffant et
300 fois supérieur à celui du CO2 il est
lié aux engrais chimiques azotées et
c'est l'une des principales sources de
GES pour cultiver des grandes cultures
on a besoin d'apporter de l'azote au sol
pour pouvoir nourrir le sol nourrir les
plantes puis en fait c'est cet azote qui
peut être transformé en protoxine et
certaines plantes ont besoin de plus
d'azote que d'autres voici
Eric Lapierre en 2019 à l'époque il
cultivait encore du maïs la plante
chouchou des agriculteurs et pour cause
elle procure beaucoup de volume et se
vend à un bon prix mais depuis
l'agriculteur a complètement abandonné
cette culture
qui est énergivore ça que toutes les
sens du mot qui est énergivore en un
train qui énergivant carburant qui est
énergivore en tête et à la surprise de
son entourage il a remplacé le maïs par
le canola il sert Montérégie on n'a pas
beaucoup de superficie en canola donc ce
nouveau T ici en tant que conseiller
aussi d'accompagner
Eric dans la culture de canola parce que
beaucoup de méconnaissance à ce sujet là
le canola se vend plus cher que le maïs
mais il procure moins de tonnes à
l'hectare sauf qu'il se récolte beaucoup
plus tôt que le maïs ce qui donne le
temps d'implanter tout de suite une
autre culture à l'automne comme le blé
et comparé au maïs le canola est moins
gourmand en engrais et en carburant ce
qui réduit les coûts de production et
les GES dans le fond ici il y a des
apports fertilisant moins important
c'est moins énergivore comme culture que
du maïs grain
à la récolte on n'a pas besoin de faire
de séchage donc ça réduit énormément la
quantité de propane qu'on utilisait
auparavant pour sécher le maïs les
changements dans la rotation de culture
ont permis à Éric Lapierre de réduire
son empreinte carbone de 23%. tout en
nourrissant plus de gens les cultures
que tu produisent maintenant vont être
directement à destination d'alimentation
humaine alors qu'avant ça passait par
les animaux en fait je sais pas plus
pauvre je suis pas plus riche j'ai la
même capacité de remboursement en
faisant autre chose ça me permet de
redistribuer les risques
et le producteur pourrait encore
s'améliorer en diminuant davantage ses
apports de lisier par exemple le Québec
et le Canada ont d'ailleurs adopté des
cibles de réduction liées aux engrais
mais elles ne sont pas contraignantes
pour l'instant le secteur agricole n'est
pas tenu de réduire ses émissions et
pour bien des agriculteurs ce genre de
cible demeure encore bien peu concrète
on a toujours la notion d'argent c'est
simple on la connaît un geste
environnemental on n'a pas de valeur
association qu'on a pas ça devient
difficile d'avoir un discours cohérent à
partir du moment qu'on a aucune valeur
associée au Québec seulement les grandes
cultures occupent des centaines de
milliers d'hectares réduire ne serait-ce
qu'un peu les émissions de ces
superficie pourrait donc avoir de grands
impacts